so growing up if you're anything like me
you probably watch a ton of pirate
movies like these and then decided that
the pirate life was the one for you this
was followed by you packing your bags
and having a brief conversation of your
mother that probably went a little bit
like this oh hey mom there comes a time
in every nine-year-olds life when they
have to become a man
a pirate man I'm gonna go sell the Seas
now and meet Jack Sparrow it's been fun
I guess I'll see you around this
conversation most likely ends in one of
two scenarios either your mum beat the
living crap out of you in two realized
that the pirate life was not the one for
you or you found out about Google and
after some quick research you realize
that the pirate life was not the one for
you if you're wondering which one of
these two scenarios I encountered let's
just say I didn't know what Google was
back then so the entire purpose of this
video is to show you guys what it was
actually like to be a pirate and of
course the crush the dreams of anyone
who still thinks that being a pirate was
cool so what better place to start them
with treasure pirates always seem to be
associated with buried treasure gold
gems and anything shiny but digging up
and burying treasure was something that
Pirates ready took part in for numerous
reasons first of all when precious
artifacts and gold are being transported
these transport ships would often be
escorted by heavily armed galleon or it
would be one of these galleons that
transports the cargo to begin with no
I'm not saying pirates in and tried to
attack these warships but it just wasn't
a smart thing to do
it's almost comparable to me running up
to a tank of a sword and be like [ __ ]
give me your gold ah crap hey Bob
there's a guy outside with a sword do we
give him our gold what do you mean we
have a tank oh okay bob says no gold
[ __ ] hopefully you can't get the point
I'm trying to convey most part ships are
wouldn't target cannons because the
chances of them emerging victorious will
quite slim but what about those parents
who were brave enough or stupid enough
to rob one of these ships didn't they
then go and bury their treasure the
answer to that question is most likely
no pirates had a very short life
expectancy so planning for the future
wasn't something that really crossed
their mind selling the loot as quickly
as possible before the pissed-off
parties could find them was the easiest
and safest solution so if pirates didn't
store treasure then how do they make
their money back in the 18th century
gems and gold are not the only
sought-after an expensive commodity
oriental spices and sugar or sign of
prestige a moth in Europe so they
fetched a small fortune it was also much
easier for pirates to target these small
immersion ships as they would offer
little or no resistance when boarded now
for those of you expecting these epic
war choreographed battles during the
Bourdon of a ship where there's a ton of
back-and-forth the new jacks
comes in dances around 50 men before
killing them all and then jumps in a
cannon and fires himself for the moon
that didn't happen most parts themselves
are not well trained swordsman the what
they lacked in skill they made up for an
aggression barbarity and downright
discuss in this some of you may be
familiar with the UFC where you end up
in a scenario where one fighter not so
the one down and then proceeds the
furrow hammer fits into the unconscious
men skull and this goes over into the
referee decides that his limp lifeless
body cannot continue well that's
probably what most part combat resembled
except there was no referee it was
fairly common for the crew of these
merchant ships just to surrender
immediately when boarded because of how
intimidating his pirates were and after
all this isn't the movies where one
precise stab would kill you it's likely
you'd be bludgeon with some blunt
objects stabbed multiple times trampled
on stabbed again and infernal aboard for
the sharks to deal with so believe it or
not pirates in actually engage in as
much combat as you would imagine and
board ownership really resulted in an
epic battle more likely one of the crew
were made an example of the scare the
rest the entire notion that all pirates
or criminals who did whatever they
wanted whenever they wanted isn't one
that was true pirates came from all
different backgrounds and each ship had
its own code of honor that those aboard
would have to abide by so it was far
from the mutinous free-for-all that we
see in the movies and TV shows most
Pirates chose the pirate life not
because they were bloodthirsty murdering
psychopath but because it was their only
option but with that being said I'm sure
there were a few pirates who were
bloodthirsty murdering Psychopaths who
saw it as their dream job speaking of
pirating as a job and there were those
who were hired to be pirates by the
government these douchebags were known
as privateers and they will essentially
be nothing more than legal pirates which
attack enemy ships and steal their
supplies in gold now some of you may be
thinking surely pirates got to travel
all around the world and sample its
finest delicacies the food must have
been good and I guess that comes down to
what you really consider good food I
think most people can agree that a
pirate's diet was pretty horrendous
be an apartment at USC for long
durations of time so the food on board
would have to last this minute salted
meat made up a reasonable portion of a
pirate's diet and that doesn't sound too
bad right and I send a piece of salted
lamb beef or chicken sounds okay but
that isn't what pirates say they were
given the cheapest cuts of meat
available most likely some kind of wild
boar anus that was heavily salted so it
wouldn't spoil but at least would the
meat being so tough you'd have time in
between each bite to contemplate what a
crap decision you made become an
apparent in the first place so now that
you've managed to slide that boringness
down your throat your mouth is probably
as dry as the Sahara Desert
you're going to need something to wash
it down with but fresh water on board
didn't stay for a very long and went
rancid quite quickly so small amounts of
alcohol
to kill the rancid taste this was called
grog and you'd have to get used to this
unfortunately for pirates the salted
meat wasn't the worst of their concerns
their diet was primarily made up of
something called hard tech and this
wasn't a nice biscuit with shortening
and other artificial flavorings added
this was flour and water mixed together
until it reached a concrete consistency
and this isn't me exaggerating pirates
would often take pieces of hard Tech and
smash it against their fist or hard
surface to break it into smaller edible
pieces but at least if you had a
disagreement of the fellow pirate you
could wait to no one's watching grab a
piece of heartache and smash him over
the head with it or better yet why not
smash yourself over the head of it and
end the misery of being a pirate you
could have both seasoned the hull tech
of some more salt but I'm pretty sure
you've already had enough of that why
not just grab a piece that's already
been infested by maggots and weevils mmm
bug infested concrete bread so the food
sucked the food really sucked but at
least you could complain to your captain
in your quartermaster right please sir
this boy anus is too tough for me can I
have some bread that doesn't have
maggots in it please oh so you like some
bit of food would you you'd like a
gourmet meal or boringness isn't good
enough for you
well I sentence you to death by hard
tech oh it's likely that any pleas for a
better menu would have been
wholeheartedly ignored which leads us
nicely to one of the biggest killers of
pirates and no it wasn't other pirates
the British or the Spanish Navy
it was scurvy fresh fruit and vegetables
are something that you wouldn't have on
board so it was quite common for pirates
to develop scurvy which is not a
pleasant disease to say the least so to
summarise being a pirate sucked there
were no glamorous adventures hunting
lost treasures in cursed Islands
living conditions were cramped and
horrible the food was horrendous and if
the other pirates the Spanish or the
British Navy didn't kill you then the
scurvy most likely would if I haven't
completely persuaded you that the pirate
life is not the one for you
then fear not because you can always
grab yourself an ak-47 head to the coast
of Somalia but piracy still occurs to
this day that is all for today's video
I've been your host
mythology and fiction explained
reminding you all to eat your fruit of
vegetables unless you want to die of
scurvy don't die of scurvy that would
suck
[Music]
kill him of heart attack Oh God
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]